hi everyone I'm back in a slightly
different location because we're going
to do something a little different today
you see
I've played video games in my day now
granted I don't play them as much as I
used to but
um one franchise of video games that I'm
certainly aware of is the Assassin's
Creed series now this is a series of
action games that essentially takes the
player to different historical locations
and then you kill a bunch of guys
basically but the interesting thing
about the Assassin's Creed franchise is
the incredible research team that they
seem to have over there at Ubisoft they
managed to recreate these historical
locations in just magnificently
wonderful ways so there's a game called
Assassin's Creed Origins which take
place in in Egypt and there's one called
Assassin's Creed Odyssey which is in
ancient Greece and and a bunch of others
and they are always incredibly well done
in terms of the historical accuracy of
course I was quite excited to learn that
the new game the upcoming game in the
series is going to take place in bhagdad
in the 9th century which is a subject
that of course is incredibly interesting
because we discuss events and people and
so on from that period quite a lot on on
this channel so last week or a few weeks
ago I'm not sure when they released a
trailer so the first sort of Premiere
trailer for this new game so what I
thought we'd do is that we'd watch this
trailer together and then I will react
and comment on on the things I'm seeing
and what I find interesting in terms of
how they portray this very significant
historical location and who am I to say
anything about this you may ask bro
I guess I'm a sort of expert
in what sense am I an expert well I
guess
my expertise would lie in Islam so I
have studied comparative religion I have
a master's degree in comparative
religion and what we do here on let's
talk religion for those of you who are
new is that we talk about a bunch of
different historical and contemporary
topics related to religion and my
expertise and particular field of
research in in the past have been Islam
and the Islamic World
which this is obviously an example of
without any further Ado let's let's
start watching this this trailer
foreign
nothing all that interesting at this
point
Lisa would be the so-called assassins I
guess which is the sort of the the group
that the protagonists of these games
belong to
[Music]
so there is something really interesting
that I that I saw uh I I noticed that
last time too and it's this book here
um this book here is really interesting
it reminds me of many many fascinating
examples of of books from the Islamic
world I am reminded of the
by a guy called kraswini which doesn't
make sense because that wouldn't have
come out at this point
um so I'm trying to figure out what if
this could be a reference to a specific
book it looks like one of those
scientific treatises that were quite
common at the time
um could be something like an occult
book two which would have looked like
this with images and so on another book
that this reminds me of is the kitabel
hayawan the book of animals essentially
by a guy called Al jahez and he did live
right around this time so this is
supposed to take place around 8 50 or
860 A.D I think and that was right
around the time that al-jah has was a
famous uh Theologian and philosopher and
and writer scholar uh wrote his books
and one of the most famous of his books
is called the kitable hayawan and this
could be that so so don't take that with
a huge grain of salt I'm totally
speculating here just based on the fact
that there's an animal in this book and
that the time period fits but it would
be really interesting if this was
referenced in that book and if perhaps
eljah has would have lived in Baghdad if
he is somehow if he somehow makes an
appearance in this game that would be
really cool
so here this is something that bothered
me about about this thing because this
certainly appears to be t t was not a
thing at this point in Baghdad it was
barely a thing in China certainly black
tea had not been invented yet and this
does definitely look like black tea and
so that to me seems like a kind of
historical inaccuracy now this could be
I guess it could be some sort of herbal
tea which was prominent at that time but
based on the color it looks like it
could be some kind of hibiscus tea which
was known as karakedia or is known as
karcadia in Arabic that usually has sort
of a reddish color this does look a
little more Brown to me which
you know again suggest something like
black tea but you know I could give him
the benefit of the doubt and say that
maybe it's some sort of herbal tea could
be hibiscus tea could be uh chamomile
was common at this time too certainly
doesn't look like chamomile but still uh
I thought that was really interesting
it's a sacrifice
I am
[Music]
[Music]
really beautiful stuff um I like the the
clothes this is one thing also that I
that I really noticed here is that
there's a lot of color in this trailer
right people people the clothes that
people wear are a lot very colorful you
see the things around the marketplace
there's a lot of color and that is I
really like that because
Baghdad in the 9th century was very
colorful people wore colorful clothes
there were colors everywhere and usually
when we see depictions of the Middle
East even in earlier games in the
Assassin's Creed series it's usually
very very sort of
um it's not very saturated right it's
very damp in terms of colors
a bit gray maybe sort of Dusty yellowish
Brown everything or people are wearing
white or black but basically that was
not what this environment looked like in
reality this was a very colorful place a
very colorful City and I really like
that they seem to be going for that look
here because that is historically
accurate and it's sort of it's a breath
of fresh air I think in terms of
depictions of of the Middle East both
today and historically
[Music]
are you ready
then out of the dark you will come into
the light so again these would be the
the so-called Assassins right with the
hoods and everything there is a really
interesting connection between the
assassins in the games and the actual
assassins of History because they were
kind of a real group even though the
game of course
take some serious creative Liberties in
terms of portraying them I made a full
video about that on the channel actually
which you can check out if you're
interested where I discuss and explore
the uh the story and the historical
context of the first game in the series
in particular and the the real assassins
so the real assassins were a group of
ismaili Muslims who because they were
persecuted would sort of um take over
and gather in these Mountain fortresses
around Western Iran and also in some
places in Syria and they became known as
the Assassins it's not entirely known
why this name came to be and they used
uh military tactics against their
enemies that we associate with the word
assassins and they would send up people
to to kill their enemies basically in
very sort of clever and undercover ways
and so that is the historical basis for
uh the assassins in these games now this
would have taken place long before the
Assassins as such were a thing the word
ismaili Shiites at this point and in
Baghdad too as far as I know but they
wouldn't have been known as the
assassins and they wouldn't have used
those military tactics at this point
either so I think in terms of the lore
of the games this is seen as some sort
of precursor to the Assassins but yeah
so that's some of the historical context
behind it and again if you want to know
more about the actual context of the
assassins and alamut and all that stuff
the actual assassins then you should
watch my my actual video on that that
topic foreign
[Music]
this is the skyline of of Baghdad
essentially you can see the Great
Palace I suppose this has to be the
palace right and maybe that's the mosque
so or the other way on so Baghdad was at
this point was very famous it was called
sometimes the round City it was built in
sort of concentric circles so at the
center of the city was the Palace of the
caliph which would be this basic sort of
place and then the rest of the city
would be in sort of circles around that
that Palace so there's a palace there in
the middle and then there was a mosque
sort of the great Mosque of the city
and that has to be this place right you
can't really see at least I can't you
can't really see that rounded shape
well I guess if you look so if it is if
this is the center of the ceiling you
can sort of see how the buildings go
around it in a sense
so it's going to be really interesting
to see how they Implement that CD
structure into the game it's a very
interesting way to build a city I always
thought that was really fascinating so
this has to be the palace and the mosque
I'm not sure which is which this could
be minarets
which means this could be the mosque and
then this would be the palace so this
was the Palace of the famous Abbasid
Caleb so this was during the Abbasid
caliphate the often called the Golden
Age of Islam right and this was the
center of that entire world this was in
many ways this was the center of the
world period this was an incredible
place of flourishing in so many fields
in in science in in literature in in it
was the spiritual and religious Center
in a sense except for Mecca and Medina
probably the caliph ruled basically all
of the Islamic world at this point from
this Palace it's you know famous calebs
like Haruna Rashid and so on and again
Baghdad at this time was basically the
center of the world people came from all
around the world it was a center of
science it was the center of these
so-called translation movement the
translation movement was in full force
at this time this was a movement where
Scholars would translate texts from all
around the world also Greek text Indian
texts Persian text into Arabic and so
promote science and philosophy and and
knowledge in general there was a place
called The betel hekma the House of
Wisdom in which all of this took place
essentially so this is an incredibly
interesting place and I really I've been
looking forward to them having this as
as a location for one of their games
because it is one of the most
interesting places and time periods in
history I think because so much is
happening in the city at the time
theological debates scientific and
philosophical development some
significant religious development in
terms of the religion of Islam a lot of
the form this is some of the formative
years of that religion it's really
really interesting so this is going to
take place in around 850 or 860 A.D I
believe which immediately makes me think
about the historical figures that might
make an appearance in the because
usually Ubisoft will include some
significant historical figures some of
the games had Leonardo da Vinci for
example or the one on ancient Greece had
Socrates so so usually there are some of
those people and I'm I'm really excited
to see if any of the significant people
from this time and place show up so in
terms of people from this time period we
have someone like al-kindi who I'm
incredibly fascinated by a great Arab
philosopher who was at the head of the
so-called translation movement
translating texts from Greek and so on
but also writing incredible texts on all
topics of philosophy and science like
logic and and metaphysics and and music
even
um and and much else he was incredible
genius really and he lived at around
this time in Baghdad actually in close
connection with with the calebs I think
he died in
875. there's also a guy called Abu
mashar who's a famous sort of astrologer
or astronomer at this point often
strongly connected with alkindi
he could also be making an appearance I
already mentioned that jaw has a famous
Theologian what hasidi Theologian wrote
the catabital hayawan and much else he
is also in this place at this time and
could make an appearance maybe even
someone like Ahmad although he died when
did he die he died in like eight
8 55 I think so maybe this is a bit too
late for him yeah so these are the kind
of things that is taking place in this
year at the time a lot of theological
debates a lot of
um philosophical and scientific
development and and just a lot of really
interesting stuff obviously the caliphs
are going to show up in some way I am
not an expert on
on the history of of of the caliph so
who's who's caliph at this point so this
is right at the end of a bastard control
basically and technically the abbasids
would still rule the the caliphate until
the 13th century when the Mongols
invaded but uh for most of that period
there were sort of only symbolic rulers
whereas other forces were actually in
control like the seljuks and others and
so this is right at the end I think or
the the last years of Abbasid rule
proper when they actually had a full
power of the Empire and so who's the
caliph at this point is
I know that my colleague xiaowish from
the channel
knows a lot about this stuff I wouldn't
be surprised if it's already made a
video about this so go check out that on
his channel if you're interested in that
but yeah the caliphs and the sort of
political situation of the abbasids is
probably going to make an appearance
that seems likely now especially
interesting for me because I have
specialized so much in what is known as
Sufism or Islamic mysticism this is also
a really interesting period because it
is in Baghdad and right around this time
that Sufism as we know it actually
starts to develop this is the sort of
birthplace of Sufism in in a certain way
sufis existed before this but is in
Baghdad in the late 9th and and 10th
centuries that we see a group forming
and many of these ideas and and
doctrines associated with Sufism starts
to be systematized and and be written
about for the first time and so so if
this is 860 that would mean that figures
like you know some of the founders of of
the Baghdad School of Sufism like
would be here even someone like Junaid
who is probably the most famous in
central Mystic and Sufi from this point
he would have been young if this is 860
he's by like 30
um but you know it's possible that he
and some of his associates you know the
sufis could be part of this do I expect
them to be probably not that's a pretty
Niche thing
although at the same time I wouldn't be
surprised if they make some sort of
appearance that would be really exciting
for me obviously
um so yeah this this place this city at
this time is just such a Melting Pot of
so much interesting stuff and it's such
a central and crucial moment in the
history of the Islamic world so yeah a
fast and Incredibly interesting time and
place
[Music]
so so the rest of the video is just a
bunch of you know action sequences that
aren't really that interesting for us in
this particular context of this video
um
yeah that's it that's that's really cool
that's really cool you know I think I
think games like this
is a really good way of educating people
about these kinds of historical
locations
um again like I said about the earlier
games like Assassin's Creed Origins and
Assassin's Creed Odyssey
um really great for
educating people and and introducing
people to the worlds of ancient Egypt
and ancient Greece and those games
usually have something called The
Discovery series which is basically just
you walking around the world and a voice
telling you about all the historical
context of what you're seeing and that
stuff is amazing I think there's a
really
important future of Education in these
kinds of in this kind of media and so uh
for us on this channel when we're
talking about religion obviously using
something like a video game which is
something that many people consume and
talking about it and talking about the
context and what's going on I think
could be really interesting and fun but
also I think something very valuable in
terms of Education uh you know going
forward thank you all for watching I
hope this was interesting I sure thought
it was really fun to just go through
this thing and start speculating about
all the the historical contexts and
things that I could find in the trailer
I would love to do more stuff about pop
culture in the future
and see how we can use pop culture to to
explore the world of religion and
history in various ways so let me know
in the comments what you thought and
also if you're interested we're excited
about this game and I will see you in
the next video which should probably be
more similar to my usual videos so I'll
see you then
[Music]
thank you